je ne pense pas l'un peu d'actu jeu
qu'on se parle de politique je constate
d'actu politique tout vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir qu'il va y avoir l'élection
présidentielle en france d'ici quelques
jours alors d'ici quelques jours avant
le premier tour depuis le deuxième tour
en quinze jours après mais je veux pas
qu'on parle de politique je veux pas
qu'on fasse de politique l'idée c'est
pas salé des 7 je me suis posé une
question je me tillie maintien mais quel
smartphone on les candidats à la
présidentielle qu'est-ce qu'ils
utilisent est ce qu'il ya un truc qui
est intéressant à venir décrypter ici
est-ce que c'est représentatif de
quelque chose d'une idée d'une idéologie
j'en sais rien je me suis posé la
question et j'ai fait ma charge sur
internet jeudi battue on va regarder
quel smartphone utilisé les candidats
présidentiels et je tombé sur un article
qui est vachement intéressant un article
du parisien et qui est signé damien qui
je passe le bonjour et qui du coup vous
dresse la liste des smartphones utilisés
par les candidats alors on va regarder
ça bien évidemment et puis si cet
article vous intéresse vous mets le lien
en bas dans la description pas ce qui
est intéressant à regarder et à voir et
donc voilà j'ai fait ma petite recherche
étaient fouillés un petit peu sur
internet pour regarder effectivement si
c'est ça et qu'est-ce qu'on arrivait à
trouver un organe est certaine candidats
où on arrive à trouver quand même plutôt
pas mal de choses on a quand même des
choses intéressantes il y a aussi
beaucoup d'archivés vous regardez
notamment au niveau des manuels macron
vous avez beaucoup d'archivés de vieux
téléphones mettant un peu compliqué de
savoir quelles étaient les smartphones
actuels quels étaient les anciens
smartphones il y avait des moyens c'est
simple on y repérer ça vous dit que
lorsqu un masque potentiellement et bien
c'est une photo qui est assez récente de
plus en tout cas 2020 donc on arrive à
décortiquer et avoir justement quel
smartphone utilise les candidats à la
présidentielle faisant les bras ça s'est
produit
je vous le dis tout de suite un
directement ici c'est pas une question
de politique on n'est pas là pour parler
de politique pour parler des avis et pas
du tout le butin je vous demanderais
vraiment vraiment quelles que soient vos
idées vos idéologies ou pas du tout si
vous vous en foutez complètement de pas
mettre de côté politique pas d'aspect
petit pas débat politique dans les
commentaires on parle de smartphones
dites-moi smartphones et que de
smartphones voilà je chacun a ses
opinions chacun son avis chacun son idée
on n'est pas là pour commenter prendre
position c'est pas du tout le but de la
chaîne dont je vous demande vraiment de
ne pas mettre de
discours partisan dans les commentaires
et s'il y en a des gens des vrais qui
réveilla parce que c'est vraiment pas le
but on va commencer par emmanuel macron
parce que manuel d'un conseil président
de la république vous n'êtes pas sans le
savoir et voilà ce qu'on arrive à
trouver alors il m'a également macro
fait il ya plusieurs téléphones de par
sa fonction de président de la
république notamment je pense qu'il est
toujours le même qu'il un mais on le
voit pas c'est un samsung galaxy s cette
age extrêmement sécurisé qui a été
d'ailleurs modifié toute la technologie
cryptosmart de la société air com donc
là on a tout nettoyé on a fait place
nette pas de bush a rien d'impossible
ses smartphones du chef de l'état
maintenant il est aussi probablement son
téléphone personnel et un autre
téléphone pour venir converser à titre
profite également avec des partenaires
bref peu importe donc là ce qu'on voit
sur les photos on voit qu'elle très
récente on voit un iphone onze pros donc
on sait en tout cas qu aujourd'hui
manuel macron at it pro et perso utilise
ici un iphone on se propose assez
intéressant de voir ce que vous venez
utiliser le chef de l'état je pense à
titre peut-être professionnels à titre
personnel a priori avant il avait deux
iphone donc j'ai vu des photos
d'archivés vont voir emmanuel macron
avec deux iphones mais des vieux iphone
ans parle d'iphone 8 d'iphone 7 ici on
pas que c'est quand même un modèle qui
est récent et un iphone on se prend
autres photos intéressantes de marine le
pen ya cette photo a été prise
effectivement c'était le parisien qu'il
l'a pris et qu'il a mis pour illustrer
son article et on voit ici quoi on voit
aussi un iphone et vous allez pas comme
un paquet d'iphone os assez intéressant
d'ailleurs on en reparlera à la fin ici
on a un iphone 10 ou un iphone 10 aces
avec une joli petit coq rouge ça vous
aura pas échappé à l'arrière mais j'ai
également des photos je pense que c'est
le même iphone mais sans la coque de
protection ici on reconnaît
effectivement le petit module sur les
photos ici avec le petit flash led au
centre donc pour moi ici si vous dis
c'est soit un iphone dit swann iphone 10
aces sont plus d'éléments pouvoir venir
vous apporter ici autre personnalité
politique à venir se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle on a luc
mélenchon l'argent ça c'est intéressant
parce que c'était très compliqué cette
photo elle faisait partie également de
l'illustration du parisien mais cette
photo elle nous permet pas réellement de
savoir ils nous disent dans l'arctique a
priori jean luc mélenchon utilisent
aujourd'hui un smartphone de huawei mais
qu'il devrait passer très prochainement
sur à samsung sauf que j'ai recherché et
ce smartphone là pour moi j'ai pas vu
quelles références de huawei pourrait
être pour moi ça sert à samsung et ça me
fait penser c'est pas exactement ça mais
ça fait vraiment penser un galaxy s est
alors j'ai une autre photo également
cette photo là on a une coque voyait que
ce petit cette espèce de petit s
derrière c'est de protection mais ça
ressemble vraiment un set c'est dans
l'idée c'est dans l'esprit envoyé le s7
avec cette partie centrale de la côte
est le petit flash led que vous avez là
et voilà ça me fait vraiment penser
maintenant est ce que c'est ça je ne
sais pas je peux pas vous le confirmer à
100% mais on n'est pas nous en tout cas
donc on serait chez samsung du côté de
chez jean luc mélenchon autres candidats
eric zemmour ou alors eric zemmour
regarder si vous voulez soumet et que
vous regardez là est-ce que vous
reconnaissez ce que ça vous parle vieil
iphone avant l'iphone 10 avant 2017 on
est donc ici non tu appelles 2010 cette
intention que en même temps que l'iphone
10 étaient sortis on a eu l'iphone 8 je
pense que si c'est un iphone 8 a priori
alors sur cette photo on le voit et si
je vais sur cette photo là c'est pas
très simple de venir repérer hop là de
venir repérer là mais pour moi ici c'est
également envoyé oui on peut être petit
module aurons ici on voit bien le flash
l'aise sur le côté ça pour moi c'est
également de la même manière un iphone 8
dont celle eric zemmour on n'utilise pas
d'iphone récents on est sur un iphone
qui remonte à minima à 2017 il ya pas
mal de candidats pour lesquels j'ai
galéré là c'est valérie pécresse alors
ses photos les gars parce que on a tous
alors au delà qu'on est la tour eiffel
et on s'en fout un peu on voit qu'on a
un masque donc là on voit donc on est
très clairement dans la période de
pandémie puis surtout on voit aussi un
très joli iphone onze pros on va revenir
retrouve ici avec une belle coque de
protection bien rouge bien pétantes
iphone os pro et j'ai une autre photo
c'est celle là où on voit bien tout
sorbonne iphone de face avec locoche ici
pour faith heidi même coque on voit bien
de masse qui vient date est en tout cas
à peu près la photo la période donc ça
va être le smartphone qu'elle utilise à
priori toujours aujourd'hui donc chez
valérie pécresse c'est un iphone os
procès chercher ensuite du côté de chez
nathalie arthaud et j'ai pas trouvé de
photo avec un smart phone même pas de
photo d'archivés ce qu'on voit dans
l'article du parisien est ce que nous
dit bien ici c'est qu'à priori elle
aurait un samsung galaxy à 52 un
smartphone qui lui permet d'avoir à la
5g de se connecter à la 5e selon le
parisien autre candidat nicolas dupont
aignan alors ici c'est un peu compliqué
à voir c'est un iphone on le voit on le
devine bien je pense deviner si
effectivement regarder la ici lé petit
module photo dont je pense qu'on a ici
un iphone à ses récents je dirais à
partir de l'iphone rose mais très
compliqué à venir à venir la firme est
comme ça on n'a pas du tout d'un faux et
donc pas griser no10 effectivement il a
un iphone maintenant qu'à l'iphone je
sais pas mais voyez quand je regarde
comme ça j'aurais tendance à vouloir
penser que c'est un iphone 11 ans
minimum mais comme il est aisé si vous
voyez un petit khabar au niveau de son
smartphone pour venir protéger l'écran
et dont on voit pas donc on sait pas
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr aussi
c'est qu'on a à faire un iphone anne
hidalgo non plus j'ai pas trouvé de
photos mais le parisien nous dit qu'elle
a un iphone ok yannick jadot de la même
manière j'ai pas réussi à trouver les
photos ce n'est pas faute de venir
chercher ici mais à priori il aurait
selon le parisien en iphone 10 jean
lassalle ça peut être extrêmement
évident non plus selon le parisien ils
auront iphone la seule photo que j'ai
réussi à trouver ses photos acquis assez
récente on voit bien qu'on a des masques
ici des personnes qui viennent le voir
il est en train de dédicacer un livre
son livre d'ailleurs et on a un
smartphone posé sur la table en
regardant comme ça brûle pourpoint je
dirais effectivement un iphone mais
voyez la photo est un peu pixo et
lorsque j'ai un zoom et bon vent
globalement plus grand-chose voyez cette
petite partie là ça me fait vraiment
venir penser à un iphone mais bon voilà
c'est pas très évident mais bon a priori
c'est ce que nous dit le parisien donc
là dessus je dirais effectivement chez
jean lassalle un iphone philippe poutou
sais pas non plus réussi à trouver de
photos donc a priori et selon le
parisien il aurait un iphone également
et quant à fabien roussel lui ça serait
comme nathalie arthaud un samsung galaxy
à 52 qui lui permet d'abord la 5g entre
autres on se parle ici d'un smartphone
milieu de gamme g est vachement
intéressant parce que sur les douze
candidats vous en avez discuté en iphone
c'est juste un peu énorme parce qu'il ya
une surreprésentation des iphone ici
dans tous les candidats à la présidence
même avec le président sortant emmanuel
macron qui a un iphone à titre personnel
je pense à titre personnel même si pour
sa fonction il aura un smartphone de
samsung hyper sécurisé macron iphone
marine le pen iphone jean luc mélenchon
ah non je dis une bêtise ça serait pas
dix candidats ça serait neuf candidats
neuf un diacre d'iphone mélenchon lui ça
serait je pense qu'on est chez samsung
zemmour iphone pécresse faune nathalie
arthaud samsung galaxy à 52 dupont
aignan iphone ali dargaud iphone yannick
jadot iphone jean lassalle iphone
philippe poutou iphone et fabien roussel
samsung galaxy à 52 ça veut dire qu'en
réalité g9 iphone et j'ai trois
smartphones de samsung dont vous voyez
quand même alors on voit que c'est les
leaders un très clairement ici mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est de se dire je
n'ai aucun smartphone de
huawei même si effectivement on nous dit
si dans l'eau selon le parisien que jean
luc mélenchon et huawei méchant c'est
plutôt un samsung je n'ai pas de
smartphone de chirurgie je n'ai pas de
smartphone dopo je n'ai pas de
smartphone de motorola je n'ai pas admis
qu'aujourd'hui aucun reste donc ça c'est
super intéressant de voir effectivement
cette sur représentation des iphones ici
tout en sachant que si vous regardez la
consommation en france selon les os
l'eau est ce qui est le plus d'appareils
en circulation c'est android c'est pas à
ios donc au niveau des personnes qui
sont candidats à la fonction suprême en
france à la présidence de la république
et bien c'est les iphone qui a au
maximum contrairement à ce qu'on va
retrouver dans l'ensemble de la
population android alors ça veut pas
dire qu'on n'est pas sûr du très haut de
gamme on sait pas bref généralement je
pense que dans l'ensemble la population
française on n'est plus dans du milieu
de gamme et le haut de gamme va être un
peu moins représentés mais j'ai pas les
chiffres ici donc j'ai pas voulu devenir
que trouvé ça intéressant de venir
regarder ça te poser cette question je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous si
vous avez des points de vue sur les
smartphones on parle que des smartphones
ici je ne parle pas une fois de plus de
politique pas de discussions politiques
pas de discours politique ce n'est pas
le but on parle ici uniquement de
smartphones et de personnes qui
utilisent tel ou tel smartphone donc si
vous voulez réagir là-dessus les
commentaires sont là pour ça pour tout
ce qui est politique il yad'autres
d'autres endroits pour mieux le faire
mais ce n'est pas le cas ici pas là
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
intéressé chasseurs à ce moment là j'ai
pas que le sujet soit peut-être chi
voyez au moment des élections du nous
parle de ça c'est un peu cheap parce que
ça énerve un peu les gens là si vous
présidentiel ici c'est pas le cas je
trouvais ça intéressant vous en parlez
pas si ça vous intéresse et si vous
voulez de 30 ans parle un peu de choses
d'actu comme ça où on vienne voir sur
des sportifs sur des candidats type
d'élection je pars là si ça vous botte
luc lemoine commentaires et puis on en
reparlera d'ici là prenez soin de vous
je vous embrasse et puis n'oubliez pas
d'aller voter en tout cas
dimanche c'est dimanche voilà ce que
vous voulez mais votez pour qui vous
voulez ça vous regarde pas mon problème
mais c'est quand même bien d'aller voter
je trouve ça intéressant voilà je vous
embrasse les bisous
[Musique]